es gibt eine ganze menge gemüse die man
jetzt im januar schon aussehen kann und
ich weiß dass das sehr verlockend ist so
früh im jahr schon zumindest zu hause
also die meisten der gemüse die ich euch
jetzt hier vorstelle sind für die
anzucht gedacht man mit dem gärtnern zu
beginnen weil er mich juckt es um diese
zeit im jahr immer schon enorm in den
fingern rauszugehen und endlich wieder
loszulegen ein gemüse könnte tatsächlich
auch schon draußen aus werden die
anderen sind aber für die anzucht
gedacht also stürzen wir uns jetzt mal
auf die samentütchen das sind echt ne
ganze menge gemüse die man jetzt
aussehen kann fangen wir an mit der
alten wäre bzw
die wahl ist da sehr ich ganz gerne die
sorte schönbrunner gold aus bieten sehr
lecker und sehr ertragreich und hier
könnt ihr jetzt schon im haus vorziehen
aber nur wenn ihr mit kunstlicht
arbeitete habe ich auch schon ein video
drüber gemacht es ist gerade um die zeit
im jahr ganz wichtig dass man den jungen
pflanzen mehr licht zur verfügung stellt
als sie einer typischen fensterbank
bekommen deswegen arbeiten wir mit led
pflanzen lampen das video dazu kann ich
euch nochmal unten in der video
beschreibung verlinken ist wäre
natürlich toll wenn man auf so einen
technischen schnickschnack verzichten
könnte das geht später im jahr auch wenn
man zum beispiel im gewächshaus hat oder
eine sehr sehr sonnige südfenster bank
aber so früh im jahr ist es sehr
schwierig jungpflanzen anzuziehen wenn
man da nicht zusätzlich noch beleuchtet
weil die einfach mehr licht brauchen als
der tag lang ist nummer zwei ist die
chili bzw wir wollen dieses jahr keine
chili anbauen weil wir noch so viel soße
und getrockneten chili und so weiter in
unserer vorratskammer haben dass das
keinen sinn ergeben würde deswegen habe
ich jetzt hier eine peperoni die ich an
bauer dieses jahr und die kann man auch
jetzt schon aus denen wir bauen die
sorte milder spiral an aber es gibt
bestimmt auch noch ganz viele leckere
er ist vielleicht ein bisschen schärfer
markt sollte er eine andere worte anbau
die beiden hier die sehe ich erst mal in
große aus tschechien also ganz viele
samen in ein töpfchen und dann petit
richtig später in einzelne töpfchen das
mache ich beim lauf nicht so das ist
nämlich nur drei der sommerlauf den
könnt ihr jetzt auch super gut im haus
vor zu gehen lasse ich dann in den
papieren in den ich sie jetzt aussehe
und wenn die pflänzchen ein bisschen
größer sind vereint sich die dann und
fern sie direkt ins beet da brauche ich
jetzt die sorte die lage aber mit ihr
haben wir auch schon sehr gute
erfahrungen gemacht ein toller
sommerlauf dann gibt es noch eine sorte
mit einem ziemlich unaussprechlichen
namen die ich mal beim self bio kanal
entdeckt habe star otago rusty camus er
wird angeblich richtig groß wir haben
das dieses jahr mal bei uns im garten
ausprobiert letztes jahr und das hat
nicht so gut geklappt da bislang eher
daran dass unsere walnuss direkt neben
dem bett wächst und nicht an der sorte
ein so die kriegt jetzt noch einen
zweiten versuch ihn auch die parodie und
die anden wäre die könnt ihr jetzt
vorziehen auch wenn ihr keine flügel
kasten oder gewächshaus habt weil die
könnt ihr direkt ins freiland pflanzen
und jetzt kommen ein paar gemüse die man
jetzt erst mal nur aussehen sollte wenn
man den vw kasten oder im gewächshaus
hat ansonsten dann liegt das nicht habt
dann einfach noch ein bisschen warten
diese ganzen sachen sind schon recht
früh also oft mache ich es so dass ich
im januar nur ganz ganz wenig aussehe
und vorträge ich eigentlich erst im
februar anfangen aber wenn man eben
möglichkeiten hat um die ernte super
frühen und den pflanzen schon früh im
jahr auch ein bisschen ein gemütliches
plätzchen im garten einzurichten dann
kann man diese sachen jetzt auch schon
aussehen aber kein stress ihr könnt euch
damit wirklich noch zeit lassen mit
allen sachen die ich jetzt hier
vorstellen und dann nummer für
blumenkohl geht jetzt auch hier sollte
neckar perle aber es gibt auch noch
frühere sorten dann auch kein kollege
wächst der kohlrabi wir es doch
eigentlich ehrlich gesagt ist gar kein
kohlrabi ich weiß gar nicht warum ich
denn jedes jahr an aber wenn ich eine
solche markt dann den super schmelz weil
der ist wirklich sehr zart der wird fast
gar nicht holzig und macht es trotzdem
richtig richtig große knollen also sind
wir auf kohlrabi steht dann ist
superschnell jetzt auf jeden fall die
sorte schlechthin dann könnt ihr jetzt
auch rote beete vorziehen um die dann in
den früchten oder ins gewächshaus zu
pflanzen man kann sie auch direkt wählen
also normalerweise mache ich mir die
mühe nicht die rote beete im haus
vorzuziehen für euch habe ich das jetzt
mal gemacht und ja bei wurzelgemüse ist
es auch immer so eine sache also rote
beete verträgt das noch ganz gut aber
sonst würde ich wirklich davon abraten
dass man wurzelgemüse im haus vorzieht
habe ich jetzt mal die sorte gebüsch
gesät aber auch eine neue sorte bin ich
noch nie ausprobiert habe vor ono heißt
die die macht so ganz lange knollen dann
bin ich auf jeden fall sehr neugierig
darauf die soll deswegen den grösseren
ertrag haben weil eben pro pflanze dann
auch nicht dran dann eine sache die man
schon auch jetzt fürs freiland machen
kann aber dann nur mit den richtigen
sorten nämlich salat ich selbst eine
andere sorte nämlich die augsburger habe
ich aber noch nie ausprobiert also das
ist jetzt keine sorten empfehlung hier
an der stelle einfach weil wir schon
sehr viel baku in unserem garten stehen
haben und nicht mehr so viel saatgut
haben und dass es dann einfach noch mal
eine ergänzung um noch eine andere sorte
ab und zu mal ernten zu können dass ich
jetzt hier eine grüne sorte die kommt
aber in den kasten oder ins gewächshaus
weil das ist keine explizite winter
salatsorten also wenn ihr jetzt salat
für das freiland vorziehen wollt dann
auf jeden fall back oder die sorte
winter marie nehmen und nicht einfach
irgendeine sorte dann kann man jetzt
auch schon zwiebeln vorziehen auch er
für den free bit kasten oder fürs
gewächshaus die habe ich jetzt auch zu
ungefähr 15 ein töpfchen gesät und da
lasse ich die dann drin bis ich die dann
ins bett um pflanze und dann
währenddessen vereinzelt bei jetzt mal
die sorte stuttgarter riesen an es gibt
aber auch noch eine reihe
toller zwiebel so hatten zum beispiel
rijnsburger bingo
so ungefähr heißt sondern ist eine
sollte mit der ich sehr zufrieden bin
aber wie gesagt das ist noch recht früh
im jahr also lasst euch ruhig noch zeit
mit den antworten das ist eher was was
sich ende januar als anfang januar
machen würde wenn ich jetzt nicht für
euch jedes video filmen würde aber wenn
es euch schon zu arg in den fingern
juckt dann geht das jetzt schon und für
alle die vielleicht einen vogel tasten
oder im gewächshaus haben die eine sache
jetzt auch schon draußen das kommt
natürlich aus wetter an also wenn es
jetzt gerade minus zehn grad ist dann
ihr noch ein bisschen warten aber wenn
es zum beispiel ein milder frühling ist
und die temperaturen okay sind dann
könnt ihr jetzt zuckererbsen sehen aber
nicht um sie dann später als
zuckererbsen zu ernten damit würde ich
noch einen monat mindestens warten
sondern um sie als garbsen triebe zu
ernten weiß epson nämlich die blätter
von erbsen schmecken total lecker und
süß und eigentlich sehr ja so wie hier
frische erbsen aus der schote und das
ist ein tolles gemüse um sich die zeit
bis jetzt die grosse erntemenge wieder
ansteht im frühling noch ein bisschen zu
überbrücken und noch mal ein anderes
gemüse mit im salat zu haben also
einfach die herbst und so ungefähr 4 cm
über dem boden abschneiden so dass sie
wieder austreiben können und dann habt
ihr ein tolles breiteres wintergemüse
wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt von dir denn
welches gemüse am besten serien solltet
dann ladet euch gerne meinen aussaat
kalender runter das ist komplett
kostenlos den könnt ihr euch ausdrucken
oder auf dem handy oder auf einem
computer abspeichern so dass die wisst
was wir also welche aussagen wir
empfehlen da sind jetzt nicht alle von
diesem mit dabei weil ich wie gesagt
nicht unbedingt jedem empfehlen würde
jetzt schon so viele aussagen zu machen
das ist echt nur für die ungeduldigen
unter euch es ist alles möglich also ihr
könnt das machen aber so wie wir es
machen tragen wir erst im februar so
richtig mit dem ausatmen an also nicht
wundern dass der kalender nicht eins zu
eins mit dem video hier übereinstimmen
ladet euch den kalender gärten herunter
dann habt ihr für jedes gemüse die
perfekten auszeit punkte nach unserem
wirklich jahrelangen erfahrungen parat
so dass sie auch laufend erkennt also da
ist auch die gestaffelte außerhalb mit
berücksichtigt und dann wisst ihr eins
zu eins was ihr machen müsst damit ihr
das ganze jahr über mit gemüse versorgt
seit und da drüben findet ihr das video
zur aussaat im februar wir sehen uns
nächste woche wieder ich freue mich auf
euch bis dann schief das coole typen und
mancher besucher kommen finden sie